génial je suis la princesse twilight
sparkle et voici mon royaume equestria
un pays plein de magie de musique
oye est le plus important d'amitié la
vie est parfaite
franchement qu'est ce qui pourrait aller
de travers
mexes essentiellement les clowns que
j'ai regardé comme ça c'est sûr vous
n'êtes pas les clowns que j'ai engagé
ryane clowe
l'audi dès 4h faveau la commandante fait
ici commencions par une reddition
complète et définitive
on vient de recevoir deux capitaines du
pm fait que j'ai jamais vu un poisson
s'est fait jeter c'est du gâteau
j'adore le gâteau
[Musique]
on a besoin d' aide pour sauver
equestria
nouveau rue
trempez là maintenant
ce papillon mais je suis la seule à
repiquer c'est moi que tu aimes feu mais
nous sommes ensemble non prompt à ces
petits poneys comment il faut faire
l'ami qu'il effleure les jolies poneys
et boulay
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non et transfère pas de stress
alors heureusement j'ai des amis
formidables qui sont là pour moi quoi
qu'il arrive
[Musique]
pink tuerie le du gâteau en visuel
visuel confirmés ont fait le ménage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
my little pony le film exclusivement au
cinéma le 18 octobre